,
WHILE MIKE MUST MAKE AN EXCUSE
FOR ANOTHER BOSTON DOCUMENT
SHOWING UP.
NEWT GINGRICH, THAT PAINED AND
NBC ACTUALLY HAVE REPORT THAT.
MULTIPLE QUESTIONS REMAIN
OUTSTANDING TONIGHT ABOUT ALL OF
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS NOW
WITH A SECOND LOCATION CORRECT?
>> LOOK AT, I THINK IS HAPPENING
IS THE DOCUMENTS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE UNRAVELING OF
THE ENTIRE JOE BIDEN BASICALLY
CRIMINAL FAMILY OPERATION, FIRST
OF ALL THE DOCUMENTS ARE LEAD
YOU TO THE PIT UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA FOR THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST GAVE MILLIONS,
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THEY REFUSE
TO OPEN THEIR BOOKS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA AMBASSADOR TO
GERMANY.
PEOPLE LIKE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND CURRENT PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN GOT A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR NINE APPEARANCES WE HAVE NO
IDEA WHERE THE MONEY WENT, WE
HAVE NO IDEA WITH THE INFLUENCE
WAS.
IT IS IRONIC THAT SO MANY OF
THESE DOCUMENT'S WERE FOUND AT
UNIVERSITY PENNSYLVANIA OFFICE.
SECOND, THIS IS ME RIGHT BACK TO
HUNTER BIDEN IS THE BAGMAN.
BECAUSE THE FIRST WAVE OF
DOCUMENTS INCLUDED DOCUMENTS
ABOUT UKRAINE AT ABOUT THE TIME
HUNTER BIDEN WAS GETTING HARD
UKRAINE ENERGY COMPANY, LARGELY
BECAUSE HE WAS THE SON OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
SINCE ALL ERUPT UP TOGETHER AND
THEN FINALLY, THIS MAKES AN
ABSURDITY OF THE ATTACK ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THE FACT IS JOE BIDEN CAN'T TELL
YOU THIS OPENLY IS NO IDEA WHY
THE DOCUMENTS, HE HAS NO IDEA
WHAT DOCUMENTS WERE TALKED
ABOUT, NOW IMAGINE RETIREMENT
VERY SECRET DOCUMENTS THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES OPENLY SAYS
SOMEHOW SOMEBODY SOMEWHERE GOT
THEM AND THEY TOOK THEM AWAY AND
HE HAS NO CLUE.
WHICH ALSO SAYS TO ME, IF THE
FBI WERE SERIOUS TO BE LOOKING
AT ALL OF JOE BIDEN'S MULTIPLE
HOMES.
TO BE LOOKING AT ALL OF HIS
OFFICES FOR LAST TEN YEARS.
JUST TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ELSE IS
OUT THERE?
THIS IS GO AWAY.
THIS COULD GET BIGGER.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A CHANGED
IT WAS ARE NOT IN THE WIDTH OF
THE PRESS ASSESSING QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS?
THE FIRST DAY, OR
DIFFERENTIATING BETWEEN WHEN
ABBA WENT DONALD TRUMP,
MAR-A-LAGO ALL TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
IN OUT YOU CAN SENSE IT I DON'T
LIKE TO WHAT SUSAN RICE NEW
ABOUT THESE DOCUMENTS.
BECAUSE SHE HAD HER HAND IN
EVERYTHING IN THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE.
SHE KNEW HER ALL THE WERE
BURIED.
SEEK ALL OF THOSE FOLKS INVOLVE
THE NATIONAL SCAREDY COUNSEL'S
TO BE INTERVIEWED AND PERHAPS
THEY WILL BE I HOPE THEY WILL
BE.
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT READS THE
QUESTION BECAUSE IT GETS RIGHT
BACK TO UNIVERSITY PENNSYLVANIA
WE KNOW THE SECRETARY OF STATE
IS BEING PAID BY THE UNIVERSITY
PENNSYLVANIA, WE NOTED THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS BEING PAID,
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE CURRENT
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
WHITE HOUSE STAFF ANY MONEY OF
THE UNIVERSITY PENNSYLVANIA
WHILE THE UNIVERSITY PENCILING
IN NOT RELEASE THE FINANCES?
THEY CLAIM THAT THE MILLIONS,
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF THE CHINESE, TO.
FINE, THEN ONE OF THE MONEY COME
FROM?
WAS THE DEAL?
IN THE FACT IS I WAS WORKING
THIS THE DONALD TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WE CANNOT GET
THEM.
IT'S ALSO TRUE.
THERE TOTALLY HIDING ALL THIS
INFORMATION I SUSPECTED A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE IS GOING TO
SUBPOENA ALL THE DOCUMENTS
UNIVERSITY PENNSYLVANIA INSIST
THEY SHARE WITH US AS I THINK
THIS IS WAY BEYOND JOE BIDEN.
I THINK THERE'S HUGE CHUNKS THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT IS THE HABIT
SANDY BERGER THE NATIONAL
SECURITY A BILL CLINTON AND
GETTING ULTIMATELY GOING TO JAIL
BECAUSE HE HAD GONE TO NATIONAL
ARCHIVE IN THE LEAST KNOCK
DOCUMENTS ARE SECRET IN HIS
SOCKS, AND IT IS UNDERWEAR.
GOT CAUGHT.
HILLARY CLINTON RAISED 32,000
EMAILS AND BROKE A HARD DRIVE
WITH A HAMMER BE VERY CURIOUS OF
JOHN KERRY HAS HAD.
INTERESTINGLY DOCUMENTS ARE
INITIALLY DISCOVERED ARE
DOCUMENTS THAT DO RELATE TO
UKRAINE INTO A RAN RELEASE
UKRAINE AT A TIME WHEN HUNTER
BIDEN WAS THE BAGMAN FOR WAS
BASICALLY A CRIMINAL FAMILY.
THE JOE BIDEN'S IS OPERATION IT
MADE PERFECT SENSE IF YOU EVER
SAW "THE SOPRANOS" YOU
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON.
>> WHO HAD ACCESS TO THESE
DOCUMENTS?
THAT QUESTION WAS POSED TO THE
PROSECUTOR TODAY I WAS THREE SHE
SUNG TO THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL'S OFFICE IS NOT
RETURNING ANYONE'S CALLS AS FAR
AS WE COULD TELL, CERTAINLY NOT
OUR PETER DOOCY'S CALLS.
SO AGAIN, WAS THERE ANY SHARING
OF OFFICE SPACE HUNTER BIDEN?
ANY CHINESE OFFICIALS HAVE ANY
ACCESS TO THE SPACE?
AS I WAS WHO THEY HAD A LOT OF
MONEY INVESTED IN THIS JOE BIDEN
CENTER WHATEVER WAS CALLED.
TO THESE QUESTIONS HAVE TO BE
ANSWERED I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY
RIGHT THIS GOES WAY BEYOND
JOE BIDEN TO A LOT OF TH